1835 the american frontier a beacon of
hope in a world choked with blood and
smog little did the hopeful citizens of
a still newly independent united states
know the evils of the old world had
followed them here sometimes it took the
form of hate of violence of desperation
and starvation but sometimes pure evil
wasn't just some abstract concept
existing in and around all of us
sometimes that evil that pure cruelty
malice and greed walks in the shape of a
man one such man was james anderson an
unremarkable name for a truly
exceptional man exceptional in the sense
that if most human beings aren't willing
to sell out all of humanity for their
own petty gain james anderson is
definitely the exception after all it's
by his design that we have as cp001
the anomaly that set the scp foundation
and our entire reality down its current
path of course you know the deal with
scp-001
not one anomaly but many a collective
designation for a vast number of entries
all of which spell beginnings or ends
for the scp foundation and sometimes
even our universe scarlet kings howling
black moons orboro cycles and gate
guardians you've heard them all and seen
the files but unlike all the others
there is no file for the factory that's
because the full story only exists in
the mind of 05-1
one of the most powerful and arguably
the oldest member of the scp foundation
he'll die before he ever commits the
story to paper some memories are just
too awful to record their details and
implications are too painful to ever
subject others to
scp-001 isn't just about anderson and
his atrocities it's about all the
terrible nightmares that unfolded
afterward and the deal with the devil
that 05-1 struck to lock them away
for now at least but it all begins with
james anderson his family had become
incredibly wealthy in the revolutionary
war and in the decades since his fortune
had only multiplied his fortunes tend to
do in the early 1800s he began work on
his beautiful and horrific magnum opus
the anderson factory it would be the
pinnacle of the industrial revolution
the manufacturing plan to end all
manufacturing plants three stories tall
and a mile wide company towns had
existed for a long time but this time
the factory itself was the town it had
everything a worker would ever need they
would live sleep play and most
importantly of all work in the same
place they would never need to leave all
their wants and needs from cradle to
grave would be met in the anderson
factory and all that mr anderson ever
asked in return was loyalty and service
was that really so much to ask from
those whom he gave everything it may
sound like a horrifying form of
indentured servitude to us but to the
people in the united states in the early
1830s this kind of security and
stability was a godsend to many
itinerant workers and unstable families
across the plains james anderson seemed
like a saint little did they know his
plans for the factory and them were
anything but safely nobody knows exactly
what type of dark magic james anderson
devoted himself to many have theorized
as to whether it was satan he worshipped
ancient pagan deities or something older
and more powerful than both in actuality
the only thing that james anderson
really worshiped was himself and the
pursuit of more material wealth and
power over his fellow man any packs he
made with evil timeless gods were just
means to an end the anderson factory was
a citadel to one man's cruelty and
corruption and every element of the
building's design seemed to reflect that
groups of eight were forced into rooms
together like battery farmed chickens to
maximize cost efficiency people worked
day and night in shifts of three
machines always rumbled and roared and
chewed when workers died in factory
accidents and their blood spilled on the
ground it seemed to reveal arcane
symbols carved into the stonework these
symbols were only visible when blood
flowed across them while people traveled
hundreds of miles to live and work at
the anderson factory they had no idea
that they were working towards slavery
subjugation and death under anderson's
iron will and in some cases fates much
much worse the factory remained in
operation like this for 40 years while
anderson himself enjoyed a positive
public reputation as a groundbreaking
industrialist how anderson got away with
his crimes for so long is sadly a tale
as old as time the factory made valuable
products and an awful lot of profit so
no matter how many rumors swirled about
inhumane practices or arcane rights
going on in the anderson factory nothing
was ever done it was just too
inconvenient to ever reckon with the
horrible truth underneath the productive
surface and it was truly productive the
factory was so huge and filled with such
a multitude of enslaved workers there
wasn't anything they didn't produce from
textiles to technology to crops and meat
the machines were always on the furnaces
always burned anderson himself seemed
obsessed with two things efficiency and
misanthropy the contempt and hatred for
humanity itself he believed his workers
were lower than him they only existed as
a means to his nightmarish ends and if
ever the workers became too injured to
work well that doesn't mean that
anderson wouldn't still find ways to put
them to good use the lucky ones starved
and neglected or broken by the stress of
work or the grinding gears of the
machines were used as material in the
production of products some were drained
of blood so that they could be used in
the forging of metal others were ground
up into meat slurry and used to pat out
the beef making it go further people all
across the country enjoying fine
anderson brand steaks had no idea that
they were actually dining on human flesh
the whole time but as we said the ones
who ended up being cooked into steaks
and hamburgers after death were the
lucky ones because at least they got to
die the truly unlucky injured workers
became the subject of james anderson's
horrific occult experiments using a mix
of twisted science and black magic he
turned men into abominations powerful
terrifying monsters stronger and more
deadly than any mortal man anderson was
building himself an anomalous army but
it wasn't just monsters there were just
as many so-called normal humans helping
him rule over the anderson factory with
an iron fist they were vicious sadists
themselves spurred on by absolute
loyalty to their immoral master it was
only after the civil war that someone
finally escaped the anderson factory and
confirmed that not only were the most
horrific rumors about the place true but
they didn't even come close to covering
the totality of what was going on there
when president grant heard the reports
he was disgusted as far as he was
concerned the atrocities of james
anderson should not be allowed to go on
a minute longer the directive was simple
find the factory free its prisoners and
put james anderson to death for his
crimes and thankfully president grant
had the perfect group of operatives for
the job they were an elite unit of
around 150 soldiers who performed a
number of dangerous missions beyond
enemy lines down south espionage
assassination psychological warfare but
these missions weren't just against the
confederates some of the enemies they
faced down south were things that could
not be explained the strange the
frightening the anomalous and the
highest ranking soldier in this unit was
a man who would one day become the
legendary
05-1 he and his men made their long and
treacherous journey to the factory a
trip that would change all of their
lives forever when they first reached
their destination they first had to deal
with anderson's security force these
were men whose cruelty and loyalty to
anderson far outweighed their skill in
combat well they may have felt powerful
when tormenting starving injured factory
workers they were quickly routed and
slaughtered by o5-1 and his team when
they ventured inside the factory they
were utterly appalled by what they saw
the inhuman conditions faced by
anderson's thousands of victims drove
them into a blood-curdling murderous
rage almost half of 05-1's men were lost
in the battle against anderson's army of
engineered monsters but in the end they
prevailed nothing would stop them in
their quest for liberation and vengeance
on behalf of all that this terrible
place had tormented they fought their
way to anderson's office where they
found him cowering under his desk for a
man as despicable as anderson only a
truly medieval execution would suffice
05-1 and his men hanged drew and
quartered anderson over a period of two
days the sadistic madman died laughing
in the end
saying that while they may kill him his
factory will never die but the factory
was no longer his in addition to the
factory's horrors 05-1 and his men also
discovered its wonders it wasn't just
normal items and monsters that the
factory produced they were also thanks
to some of anderson's arcane deals the
world's leading producer of anomalous
items skeletal horses that never tire
shadow cloaks that could transport the
wearer to different dimensions toy guns
that fire real bullets even yo-yos that
could flay the skin from anyone they
touched these were anomalous objects
that could shift the balance of global
power items that could give them an
advantage against the things that go
bump in the night while others among
them were greedy or fearful the inner
circle of o5-1 were united in a singular
purpose using the anomalous they can
control to contain the anomalous that
they can't this group took over the
factory making it site alpha their first
ever containment facility and came to be
known as the 05 council with funding
that came from a mix of blackmail and
friends in high places this organization
a burgeoning scp foundation grew more
and more powerful over the ensuing
decades the tools they gained from the
factory were pivotal in the continued
success of their mission and as they
discovered more anomalies they also put
these anomalies to good use but in 1911
05-1 and his new organization came up
against an enemy that even the factory's
tools couldn't help them defeat a
warrior race known as the fae so named
because their only weakness seemed to be
a vulnerability to iron but these beings
were an order of magnitude more powerful
than humans or the beasts they'd once
faced in anderson's factory the fae
handed them defeat after defeat but soon
humiliation became decimation when an
army of the fey led an assault on the
factory it was a day that only 05-1
remembered the fae slaughtered everyone
every guard every researcher every
member of the o5 council they swept
through the factory like a plague of
locusts leaving only death and
destruction in their wake only o5-1
escaped and survived and that's only
because he ran as he fled from the fairy
forces through the halls of the factory
he came upon a door he'd never seen
before a huge golden door covered in
aramaic script he fled inside entering
the very heart of the factory
inside he saw the floating dead body of
james anderson bathed in red light now
he was little more than the mouthpiece
of the factory itself or rather the
great and unknowable powers working
behind it the factory gave 05-1 an offer
just like the offer it had given
anderson before it would give them the
power to turn back time and destroy the
fae saving everyone that they'd slain in
the factory but in exchange
all of them would forever belong to the
factory and in a moment of weakness and
fear
05-1 took the deal the clock was turned
back to before the battle this time 05-1
and his compatriots all of whom except
him had no idea what had happened had
the horrific weapons required to
slaughter the fae weapons that nobody
mortal or otherwise could possess they
repelled the invading force easily but
knowing the horrors that came before
05-1 refused to stop there with the
power of the foundation and the factory
behind him he hunted down and murdered
every last ferry driving their species
entirely into extinction as far as o5-1
was concerned it was them or him but
with the fey utterly destroyed and the
foundation's superiority assured a
shadow was laying over 05-1 he'd made a
deal with the factory and someday it
would want its pound of flesh 05-1
rather than facing the consequences of
his actions decided to run and hide he
had the factory decommissioned and
buried under the rubble never to be used
as an active foundation base again but
just because they were done with a
factory doesn't mean that the factory
was done with them one day a toy gun
appeared on o5-1's
a toy gun that fired real bullets just
like the ones they found in the factory
a century before the factory was still
waiting for its repayment with every
anomalous item from the factory that the
foundation used the terrible place only
grew in its power since the resurgence
05-1 has been sending the factory
sacrifices d-classes dead and alive as
well as agents and researchers but as
time goes on it seems that these
sacrifices aren't satisfying the factory
anymore it wants more more than 05-1 can
ever stand to give it and when 05-1
refuses to give the factory will begin
to take and what the factory wants
sooner or later the factory will get now
go check out children of scp-001 the
scarlet king is scp-999 really his son
and scp-001 the oroboro cycle the full
epic story explained for more
frightening and fascinating takes on
scp-001